carolina ribera ni es muchísimas gracias
por estos minutos con france24 en
español quisiera preguntarte por
supuesto en primer lugar cuál es el
estado de salud de tu madre giannina
muchas gracias santiago bueno este el
estado de salud y madre es muy crítico
es muy complicado en todos estos meses
ya se ha deteriorado muchísimo su salud
y eso es lo que a mí me preocupa como
hija las consecuencias que pueda tener
esta huelga de hambre pero es todo un
grito de auxilio que ella tiene que ya
ha tenido porque no se puede vivir en
tanta injusticia el día de mañana les
quieren sentenciar a 12 años por un
delito que nunca existió por un golpe de
estado que nunca existió y hasta el día
de hoy no nos muestran pruebas ni el
ministerio público ni los jueces sin
embargo la están castigando a mí más de
por delitos que no no existe mi madre
está sufriendo un castigo mi madre es
inocente y no tiene que probar su
inocencia sin embargo los sicarios de la
justicia jueces y vocales en bolivia
tienen que probar que ella o tienen que
inventarse las pruebas que para condenar
la carolina bueno precisamente recién
hablabas del juicio que comienza mañana
en contra de tu madre qué expectativas
tienes creo que están dadas las
condiciones y las garantías necesarias
para que comience
no hay ninguna garantía porque primero
están haciendo el juicio virtual mi
madre debe tener un juicio presencial
como corresponde por ley pero lo que
quieren es callarla mal haciendo un
juicio virtual en una y ahí es una de
las irregularidades porque el
procedimental mente todo esto da un
efecto ilegal hay +16 irregularidades en
todo el proceso a mi madre la primera
que se realizó el 13 de marzo cuando la
secuestraron y se la llevaron a otra
ciudad para éste ponerla en detención
preventiva fue sindicada ninguna
situación tiene orden de allanamiento
todo ni notificación ni siquiera estaba
en el proceso y en 1.094 ahora ampliaron
el proceso de incluyeron a ella y fueron
con operativos de más de más de mil
policías para llevarse a la otra ciudad
y meterla presa estas zonas ilegalidades
que sufrimos en bolivia él no existe una
justicia imparcial en bolivia y no
pedimos impunidad lo que pedimos es un
juicio justo que se respete en medio del
proceso que se le devuelvan los derechos
robados de mi madre y que también se den
las garantías fundamentales como la
presunción de inocencia y que ella se
pueda
tal ahora él está elevando juicio de
mérito como ex mandataria de estado sin
embargo la tienen por la vía ordinaria y
ahorita esta inferencia esté enfrentando
tres procesos por la vía ordinaria caso
golpe 1 y el caso golpe dos que lo han
ajustado
esté adelantando todos los plazos yendo
en contra la constitución política del
estado y en contra del código penal
yo quisiera leer la carta de mi madre
que
escribió que escribió diciendo que es
declarándose en huelga de hambre
boliviana hoy desde mi celda en
miraflores la paz tomó una de las
decisiones más duras de mi vida hoy
ingresó en huelga de hambre estoy
desesperada de ver un país sin justicia
en delay veo que mi acción final podrá
ayudar a que la comunica a que la
comunidad internacional
entienda que en bolivia la justicia es
de evo morales y el universitatea cobra
estoy enferma pero mi última fuerza la
dedicaré para mostrar al país y al mundo
que estos males del poder no podrán
borrar de la historia
que cometieron fraude fueron encontrados
y renunciaron escapando del país a mi
hijo
bolivia es hermosa
carolina varón en la noche por ella te
pido disculpas tuve que interrumpir te
hacia el final debo agradecerte
muchísimo estos minutos en france 24
pero